[Music]
welcome to AI the future of us a podcast
Style video series that explores the
ways in which AI is shaping our future
and how we can prepare for the changes
that lie ahead I'm your host Brad
thickener and today we are joined by
Forest Brazil who is Google Cloud's head
of developer media thank you for here
being here today for us
right it's great to be here
two we are seeing you know phenomenal
amount of changes in the in the world of
AI and you know it is also impacting the
devops uh you know Community a lot as
well so in your opinion what are the
most significant ways that AI is
currently impacting the devops you know
people
well you know AI has always I should say
uh devops has always been a field that's
been automation driven and in a way
those of us who've been in devops I've
been uh closely tied to the devops world
for you know more than a decade now and
it's always been about kind of
automating yourself out of a job and
moving on to the next thing right we did
this when we were slinging physical
servers and we moved them to Virtual
machines we did this when we moved out
of the data center and into the cloud we
did this as we moved from you know lift
and shift Cloud migrations into more uh
managed Services we did this now as
we're starting to move more toward
serverless and kubernetes and these
higher and higher levels of abstraction
but in some ways that the job has never
changed in that time we're always
seeking that next level of automation
we're always seeking uh ways that we can
continue to provide safe resilience
quick deployments of code to production
and maintenance and security of the code
that's there none of those
responsibilities for devops folks are
changing whatsoever in the world of AI
but what we're seeing is that certain
tasks that historically have been
kind of time consuming and have taken a
while you know writing that backup
script porting that code from this
language to that language generating
this giant piece of yaml that you're
going to use to configure whatever
you're deploying it turns out that like
AI code assistants make some of that
stuff easier to do now that's not to say
that it's perfect it's not to say that
there's not responsibility on your part
to continue to look at that stuff and
make sure that it's correct but it is
tremendously speeding up the amount of
uh time and effort that you need to
spend actually generating this code from
scratch and I think for a lot of devops
folks that's exciting right because
especially if you're you know you're not
like a software engineer by vocation or
a software developer you don't think of
yourself as someone who just writes a
lot of code day in and day out it could
be the case that having that scaffolding
generated for you by AI actually is is
really nice and so I in that in that
respect I think it's it's an exciting
thing for devops folks to look at where
AI can help but again there are
downsides that come with that as well
you got to be much more careful about
what's getting generated and make sure
that you actually uh are comfortable
signing off on that you've got to take
professional responsibility
so what I'm hearing then that you know
their office people are not going to be
losing their jobs they'll be using to
improve their productivity and at the
same time be really careful that the
output that is generated from these you
know tools is really up to the standard
and it will meet the requirements
yes I want to be I never want to say you
know oh nobody's going to lose their job
here because again going back to the
very beginning of the ops world because
the landscape changes and the level of
abstraction changes uh if you get really
comfortable using a particular set of
tools and really stake your professional
identity to that you're probably always
going to be at risk 20 years ago there
were a lot of Ops people who were kind
of point and click uh like you know
working in Windows server and this sort
of thing and they just weren't
comfortable coding and those have become
increasingly fragile jobs as automation
has taken over and I think you're going
to see that with AI too you'll hear a
lot of people saying well you don't
really need to learn to code now or you
won't need to learn to code soon because
these AI tools can can spit out a lot of
generated code for you I actually think
that's quite the opposite I think it's
going to be more important than ever
that you learn to code that you get very
comfortable Reading Writing
understanding code because again there's
going to be so much more code generated
now the barrier to creating code and
config has been lowered by these service
services so it's going to increase the
absolute amount of code that's out there
in the world and someone's going to have
to debug that stuff Harden it maintain
it you know that person could be you you
could make an awful lot of money doing
that but if you're not comfortable just
diving into that code space then you
know I think you're going to see your
opportunities increasingly sidelined
yes I I totally agree with that actually
and and where do you see the you know
the most pressing ethical considerations
you know surrounding you know AI
development and use in particular around
the devops as well
that's a very interesting question
because I think as as devops people we
don't often think of our work as having
a strong ethical component you know
we're we're making sure the lights stay
on right that's kind of that's kind of
cut and dry there's not a lot of nuance
to it but uh first and foremost anytime
you're working with these AI these
systems that are capable of generating
code you've got to be very careful and
knowledgeable about what you put in
there uh we've seen a bunch of news
stories over the past few months about
folks who have put proprietary or
sensitive things uh into these services
not realizing or not being aware that uh
they're then being used as training data
or possibly even being exposed directly
to uh folks outside of your company's
control so anytime you're looking at
using one of these AI assistant type
Services make sure that you're very very
clear and that your company's very clear
about whether it's okay for you to be
putting their proprietary code in there
and what's going to happen to it once it
gets there there our services that you
know are cool to use I'm sure just make
sure that you know you you think very
carefully about that you don't want to
get yourself into an ethical conundrum
at your company and as well I think this
gets really important when you think
about how you're going to conduct
yourself professionally as it relates to
Bringing new people into the industry
I've heard a lot of people say you know
hey uh this AI assistant is almost like
my new Junior engineer I can give it
tasks and it'll spit back code at me I
don't need to bring on an apprentice I
don't need to have someone new come in
and learn beside me anymore I think
that's a very short-sighted and honestly
somewhat professionally unethical way of
thinking I think it's going to continue
to be very important that you find ways
to bring in humans into that Loop make
sure that they're available to learn and
that you're not kind of uh you just
relying on your own context to be the
only human in the loop uh otherwise you
know eventually you're going to move on
uh the the company the team's not going
to have that human expertise that they
need so you're going to have to think
about ways to bring in juniors and find
ways for them to learn and grow even in
the presence of AI That's a big open
problem in the industry I think there's
a lot of value to be gained by helping
to figure that out but there's
tremendous danger in assuming that AI is
going to eliminate the need for you to
continue to grow the next generation of
Engineers I would never assume that
yes I totally agree and I think we'll be
seeing you know Engineers will become
more and more important on the contrary
actually because the ones that were
really competent who can understand what
the court can do I think Will Shine
through as well right I think you're
yeah you're absolutely right about that
I mean it's hard for us to Intuit about
leverage right kind of in the same way
it's hard for us to think about
exponential growth our brains don't
really work that way but having these AI
tools at your fingertips massively
increases the amount of Leverage you're
able to provide as a senior engineer now
what that means probably directly for
your career is you want to make sure
you're getting as close to the core
value prop of the business as possible
there's a lot of devops people out there
that are working on internal tools there
are your seven layers of tools deep
removed from the customer uh and you
know your customer is an internal team
who's a customer of an internal team Etc
et cetera uh and while yes there can be
value in that I think now is the time to
think very seriously about hey is this
little you know internal set of scripts
that I'm maintaining is that just
something that you know could probably
be more or less generated by Ai and I
need to go work on what's really really
effective and highly leveraged for the
company those type of roles are the
things that are going to uh be highly in
demand and uh have a lot of future as
opposed to things that just seem kind of
undifferentiated
and with that so what are the some key
skills that you know individuals should
possess to be successful in this new era
that we are entering right from the
devops point of view and that's that's
kind of my last question as well to you
for us so yeah because it's everyone's
mind that you know where should I invest
where what should I go and learn in this
new world
of course now just to be clear there are
still lots and lots of opportunities to
do things that are a lot older than AI I
mean there are still a lot of
Enterprises out there out there that are
that are catching up to you know the the
technology world of 2007 let alone the
world of 2023. so I'm not trying to say
that everything's going on overnight now
ai is the only thing you need to know
but if you're looking future forward you
want to put yourself at The Cutting Edge
we already talked about make sure you
learn to code that you're confident
about that that you keep expanding what
I would call your uh personal mental
context window AI systems llms they have
this little context window of a few
thousand text tokens that help them
provide relevant answers to your
question and that's all they've got you
as a human being have a tremendously
wide context window that's made up of
your general technical expertise you've
learned over your career as well as your
specific knowledge about your company's
constraints and business needs That's
Unique value you bring to the table so
continue to widen that grow that
practice learning and training don't get
mentally lazy and just try to make AI
fill in all these gaps for you you have
a ton of unique human value to bring
into the table so lean into that we
already talked about getting close to
the the business's value prop right not
getting sidelined seven teams deep in
internal tools that aren't really moving
the needle
um but I would say use these AI
generated tools where they make sense if
there's going to be a lot of them
there's going to be whether it's
generative AI tools like a Bard or a
chat GPT or whether it is just AI being
further injected into the operational
Services the managed services that you
use in the cloud today uh your part of
your job as a professional software
engineer professional devops person is
to make smart and cost effective choices
about when and how to deploy to
integrate to use those tools sometimes
we call that vendor engineering and
that's only going to get more important
it's going to be a long time before any
AI is pulling the trigger on whether or
not to buy a tool right that's something
you're going to have to evaluate very
carefully compare these tools make the
choice that provides the most leverage
for your business uh and then finally
one specific piece of advice I'll throw
in figure out I know you'll like this
because you come from the data world
like the future belongs to data
scientists but let's be honest data
scientists can be kind of sloppy you
know I I mean look at those Jupiter
notebooks and all this there's a lot of
Need for data engineering prowess I mean
that's pipelines that's uh you know uh
clusters those are things that you
understand as a devops person if you're
looking for a tweak to put on your
career that I think will provide a ton
of opportunities for you look into what
it would take to become a data engineer
it's it's your same wheelhouse of work
but it's work that directly supports the
creation and deployment of these Ai and
ml systems it's going to be much in
demand for a long time to come
for joining us today for us I agree with
you it is more about I think uh
playing with the bricks right so you we
will have a lot of bricks out there and
how we engineer that to get the optimal
solution I think will be the key we are
just going to have more support doing
that it has been incredible and
insightful to hear your thoughts on this
and we look forward to seeing how AI
will continue to shape the world around
us and we hope that our viewers will be
inspired and embranced the in a
potential opportunities thank you
wonderful thanks so much
foreign